Basava
what do Hannibal's elephants and this RS
q3 have in common Ponder's montes not
just the color trekking across the Alps
howdy organized a special tour to test
the mountain credentials of its
high-performance compact SUV from
Klagenfurt Austria to Monaco and back
Montes was desperate to ride along for
at least a short section of the
expedition let's see how the car does on
those tough Alpine passes the RS badge
from the German for racing sport adorns
outies highest performance models the
lowdown on the souped-up q3 five
cylinders a two and a half liter
displacement 228 kilowatts but why pick
the smallest member of the Q family for
the upgrade the Porsche Cayenne cemented
the arrival of performance SUVs
howdy has now taken the small as SUV in
its range and produced a real pace
monster the RS q3
there is also an sq5 but no RS q5 that
makes the RS q3 the sportiest SUV in the
Audi family that Todd the sparkliest SUV
finally the Swiss Alps are twisty and
tricky terrain Quattro four-wheel drive
makes light work of those hairpin bends
while the engine is loads of fun along
straight sections there's been major
growth in the compact SUV segment
explains outies Thomas Zimmerman OD
wanted to become the first car maker
among its rivals to launch a car like
this the regular q3 model debuted in
2011 the RS versions 228 kilowatts see
it out power BMWs x1 and the new GLA
from Mercedes it also outstrips them on
the price front however prices for the
RS q3 and Germany start at fifty four
thousand six hundred euros
the new model shares the features of
other RS models explains the Audi
project manager such as a 5-cylinder
turbo familiar from the rs3 it's great
for everyday use thanks to the
functionality of the interior then there
are its off-road abilities too but
off-road talent seems less important
than the view from the high seating
position even so the RS is 25
millimeters lower than the regular q3 it
would be montez's first choice for
tackling off-road territory all the
off-road parts that are normally housed
in raw plastic with a regular q3 now
have a paint finish and pick up
scratches very easily this is very much
an SUV for the streets SUV finished also
definite even with suspension on the
firm side the RS q3 does give you that
sports car feeling despite the high
center of gravity the car makes the dash
to 100 kilometers an hour and 5.5
seconds top speed is electronically
limited to 250 we took a closer look at
the new model at an altitude of over
2000 meters the revamped front is
dominated by the single frame radiator
grille with a honeycomb design grid the
wheel wells have flared out a little the
new addition has shiny painted trim
everywhere
a roof spoiler optimizes the downforce
when you pick up the pace the RS q3 may
not be your ideal Alpine escort but it
is more fun tackling curves than driving
straight ahead
that's something the great grip on the
steering wheel and the precise steering
response ensure howdy claims an official
fuel consumption of 8.8 liters per 100
kilometers a figure that is indeed
achievable but only if you don't fancy
much fun at the wheel
gumption hunched mutt has found the
expedition challenging because you're in
a fast car but only as fast as the
driver in front and after eight hours on
the road it's time to relax